stangen die schnee sprühen sieht
unspektakulär aus doch hier in der
zentralschweiz steht eine weltneuheit
denn das system funktioniert ohne strom
nur mit wasserdruck aus dem speichersee
wir treffen felix keller gletscher
forscher aus dem engadin er will
gletscher weltweit retten ja gletscher
wieder wachsen lassen mit hilfe des
neuen beschneiung systems weltweit sind
über 200 millionen menschen direkt
abhängig
betreffend der wasserversorgung von den
gletschern
wenn die gletscher verschwunden sind
dann werden deren existenz in frage
gestellt sein
der glaziologe zeigt uns einen plan
quer über den gletscher sollen
beschneiung seile gespannt werden was
schneider als hat eine ähnlich aus wie
eine luftseilbahn nur anstelle dass eine
bahn fahren kann werden wasserleitungen
und luft leitungen aufgehängt zeit und
direkt an der wasserleitung werden dann
diesmal gießen aufgehängt sein
an der hochschule in luzern wurden die
schneeeule entwickelt hier tüfteln die
forscher am idealen schnee für die
gletscher rettung wie kann beschneiung
funktionieren wenn hoch oben der strom
fehlt ein teil dieses druckes nutzen um
druck 15 zeugen die wir ebenfalls
brauchen zum beschneiden
versuchskaninchen wird der schweizer
moderat gletscher er verliert an
sommertagen eine million tonnen eis die
schneise sollen ihn ab dem frühjahr mit
schnee bedeckten und wieder wachsen
lassen
wir möchten den mord roger deshalb
beschneiden weil wir weltweit
feststellen dass sich die gletscher
zurückziehen und unsere kinder die
werden wahrscheinlich mich fragen ob wir
das nicht gesehen hätten
sondern was wir getan haben das neue
schweizer verfahren könnte die
lebensdauer eines gletschers um 50 jahre
verlängern
der moderat gletscher soll vorbild
werden für die gletscher rettung überall
auf der welt